now that air quality is challenging
those with breathing issues but you can
help keep the air in your home a little
bit cleaner with an air purifier now
those are kind of pricey uh so you
they're also some inexpensive ways that
you can help clean the air in your home
and one of those is to buy one of those
furnace air filters that's called an
fpr-10
and we found really a simple way is just
to take one of those filters like you
see right there and tape it to the back
of a normal box fan so when the air is
pulled into that fan it's actually
coming through that filter and it's
cleaner experts also recommend keeping
your windows and doors closed as much as
you can and change your normal air
filters in your home regularly poor air
quality can put certain groups in danger
it's very scary i could i could be
triggered at any time and it could
trigger me into going into the hospital
well moselle there that you just heard
from she has respiratory illness and
breathing
challenges already so the smoke in the
air has really been compromising her
breathing ability
the smoke advisory has now been extended
through friday and it's categorized as
unhealthy for sensitive groups like
moselle that we just talked about and so
i talk about it all the time nate as
well and ted and sally that when we have
air quality advisories it's just putting
you on alert that that air is not good
and especially for people that have
respiratory illnesses but it's not good
for any of us to be breathing